good morning John now you may have heard
that young women are insecure and also
young men and also old men and old women
and kite surfers and musicians and CEOs
and you and mean everyone deals with it
scary but there are a lot of young women
here on YouTube and also I think that
they've been told their entire lives to
base their self-worth on whether or not
they are admired by men so there's an
entire genre of video on YouTube
dedicated to the idea of telling women
what men like to see and am so a figure
since those videos do very well I should
hop on the man wagon myself and tell you
what boys look for in girls in
Ethiopia's Caro tribe woman's scar their
bellies as a form of sacred ceremonial
tattoo that is found to be very sexy the
cayenne tribe of Thailand will use brass
rings to compress their chests and
clavicle so that their neck appears very
long the mercy of Ethiopia inserts
ceremonial plaques into their lips to
attract a man in Japan women have their
teeth cosmetically unstraight and
because crowded teeth is seen as
endearing by the tribe an Indonesian
thinks the height of sexiness is pointy
teeth so they sharpen their teeth with
files in 19th century Europe women wear
garments that squeeze their waists the
tiny tiny shapes while in Mauritania
women send their daughters off to fat
camps to eat 10,000 calories a day
because their stretch marks are seen as
the height of sexiness meanwhile in
America women appear beautiful by
painting their faces and shaving their
bodies likewise different cultures have
different standards of beauty for men
and England they wear really tight pants
for example and I wish I could pull
those pants off okay I have a point
several but my main point is that there
is very little objectivity when it comes
to human mate selection we're crazy we
don't make any sense and thus since
whether or not someone wants to date you
is apparently based on complete
randomness it's kind of a super terrible
thing to base your self-worth on and
this is regardless of your gender by the
way I do think that it is more of a
problem for women I saw a post on tumblr
the other day it was wonderful it said
how do boys look so hot and they never
have to wear makeup is one of those
moments where suddenly you noticed the
water you've been swimming in your whole
life
right like we're always surrounded by
culture we never notice it's there
that's how cool
sure works wasn't that moment you're
like yeah how come boys don't have to
wear makeup to look hot and girls do
those boys without makeup don't look
better than girls without makeup but in
our culture they do and I think that's
because we're pretty adamant about the
fact that women's value is based not
entirely but significantly on their
beaut and that a lot of their purpose is
to be attractive to men which is messed
up course there's nothing wrong with
wanting to express yourself through your
physical appearance everybody does that
to some extent makeup and fashion are
super cool ways to express yourself
we should express ourselves in all of
the ways that we can find to express
ourselves in with our words and our
actions and our ideas and our clothes
our fingernails and our haircut on
anybody drag on you for expressing
yourself however you want to do it
there's nothing wrong with wanting to be
appreciated for how you look I want to
be appreciated for how I look but there
is so much more to you than that there's
so much more to life than that girls are
not the photons that hit the corneas of
boys garlis of your gender regardless of
their gender you do not exist do please
someone else you exist
for your own sake John I'll see you on
Tuesday
did you ever want
- back where we were before trial abouts
Spyder